XCOM - launched with mod support and
right off the bat was some genuinely
useful tweaks and fixes to easily add
into a game but as times gone on other
mods have surfaced is a few of our
favorite slightly more off-piste efforts
let's kick things off with a boys pack
for everybody's favorite friend Chandler
from friends no turning back are you
scared are you
no thanks to Jake the Pug you two can
add a transponster to your squad to help
take on the weenus alien threat could
this mod be any better all right that's
it
give me your underwear come on
if you're looking to make your squad
look a little fancy then you already
know that you can hit up the Steam
Workshop or Nexus mods to find some new
bits and bobs we especially like the
look of too fancy for hours days by cat
FL which offers a quirky variety of
novelty hats face props and tattoos to
spruce up your soldiers target
neutralized
if you feel your copy of ex-con to is
lacking an anthropomorphic phallus then
good news because everybody's favorite
surprise dick but is available as a
textures mod courtesy of Rev --ax use it
as face paint or even a regrettable
tattoo what a time to be alive
gotta go fast
well Madre de fini has created this
monstrosity take sonic out into the
battlefield and speed past your alien
enemies squad located note this mod
doesn't actually make your soldiers go
any faster who doesn't love the soothing
dulcet tones of famed painter and twitch
streamer Bob Ross we don't make mistakes
we have happy accidents well with the
Bob Ross voice back from TDC 733 you can
enjoy his comforting voice from the
battlefield while you're dodging gunfire
from behind happy little trees yeah oh
look at that
if you can't wait for the next Star Wars
released then why not make your own
version with the Jedi class mod from
Marv Weezy you can train your squaddies
to become one with the force and
powerful Jedi's complete with a various
amount of force powers and of course
laser swords it's all ogre now with this
shrek character options mod again from
de fini shrek can be loved and shrek can
be life for your squad admittedly
there's a little bit of clipping with
the character model but when you're out
in ocher watch in the thick of the swamp
none of that matters so there's a few
fun bizarre mods to take a look at in
XCOM - have we missed any of your
favorites let us know for all the latest
on XCOM to keep your GameSpot commander